[Music]
welcome to the Commission's press room
for the weekly meeting following the
college meeting that's all can I welcome
our two commissioners the myth is
they're avramopoulos and Julian King who
will be presenting the dish of the day
which is the report on the security
union let me just deal with the rest of
the colleges agenda I'll give you a
quick readout then we can focus on the
main dossier we have seen the statement
we published earlier today where
president Yunker welcomes also in the
form of the college the swift and
intensive efforts by Prime Minister
Boyko Borissov and the Bulgarian
authorities who in cooperation with law
enforcement agencies from other member
states have now arrested the suspected
murder of Nash of journalist Victoria
Marie Nova while we welcome the rapidity
with which joint efforts have brought
justice in this case our thoughts always
remains of course with the family and
friends of Victoria then Michel Barnier
our chief negotiator briefed the college
this morning on the latest state of play
around the article 50 negotiations with
the United Kingdom he recalled the
decisive progress must be made in time
for the October European Council next
week and negotiations at the technical
level will continue this week then the
secretary-general of the Commission also
provided a brief update on the state of
play of the Commission's preparedness
work and recall the importance for all
stakeholders to prepare for all outcomes
and at all levels final more liquid
laser on finally Commission had a
presentation from the chair they
dependent Europe
in the school board Neil's Tiger Singh
who presented to the college the board's
annual report it will be published later
this afternoon the report provides a
comprehensive and independent assessment
of the implementation of the stability
and growth pact switching giving the
floor to the commissioners I would like
to welcome two groups that are with us
today a group of young colleagues from
leaders action in Germany in common and
a group does not least woman Kyoto's
Romanian journalists welcome to you
please commissioner you have the fly
thank you thank you good morning
everybody
well you all know that today's security
environment is more complex less
predictable and more quickly evolving
than at any time in recent memory
threats come from a great variety of
sources and manifest themselves in ways
which challenge our security frameworks
our institutions and our democracies
themselves cybercrime a lateral
interference and disinformation
campaigns from hostile foreign actors
destabilizing hybrid operations
targeting economies and social
structures terrorism those coming from
outside intending to cause harm and the
lone wolf that are radicalized almost
overnight on the Internet and resort to
do-it-yourself terrorism with knives and
trucks and while we have not had an
organized major terrorist attack since
Barcelona in August 2017 we cannot be
complacent
several attacks have been prevented by
our member states but too many low tech
attacks who are still committed it is
this last threat that is probably the
toughest to defend ourselves against in
order to tackle the homegrown
self-radicalized terrorists we are
fighting the battle of ideas and we have
to win this body about the cases much
less easy to define grasp or predict
where the thread is not perceptible in
most cases until it is too late but that
does not mean we cannot prevent them and
if we had done what we have been doing
in the last year's believe me we could
have predicted and prevented some tragic
events from happening three years ago
information is at the center of this
challenges but also our efforts first by
eliminating from the web the terrorist
content which inspires people to violent
extremism glorified atrocities or gives
advice how to attackers this why we have
proposed legislation to detect and
remove terrorists content online within
one hour and to establish a clear and
harmonized legal framework across the
European Union to prevent the misuse of
the Internet today we call on the
council and the Parliament to urgently
move forward on this proposal in
parallel we will continue to work with
Internet companies within the Voland
a framework of our EU internet fall to
further reduce terrorist content online
secondly we need the right information
at any moment and any place about a
potential suspect including at our
external borders here we have made
enormous progress over the past years
and all the relevant pieces of
legislation are either already being
prepared for implementation or waiting
to be agreed on and adopted yesterday
for example the European travel
information and authorization system
entered into force paving the way
towards full operationalization in 2021
in parallel the entry/exit system is
also being prepared to be operational in
2012 the Schengen information system
which has become the most used security
database in Europe will soon be
strengthened further when our proposed
reforms it will include the immediate
obligation to insert alerts on terrorism
and is expected to be adopted next month
what is paramount in all this migration
border and security systems is that they
talk to each other
finally they talk to each other because
it was not the case before I really
count of the European Parliament at the
castle to finish their work on
interoperability by the end of this year
we have no time to lose and
interoperability can be a game changer
for the security of our citizens thirdly
information is not only crucial in order
to prevent threats or attacks against
our security but also to in
the gate and prosecute our proposal to
improve the gathering of electronic
evidence across borders will also make
easier advocate to obtain evidence from
service providers in other countries in
order to investigate and prosecute crime
including terrorism on cybercrime in an
effective manner here too we call on the
European Parliament and the council to
work on this priority legislative
initiative as a matter of urgency dear
friends the grand sum of all these
actions is not a reaction to a crisis it
is a paradigm shift the security union
we're building is about building trust
sharing resources and facing threats
together the sheer breadth and depth of
the initiatives you see in today's
security union report is testament to
the added value of the European Union
for the security of our citizens as we
come closer to the European elections
this added value needs to be shown and
communicated to our citizens because
only within the European Union they can
really feel safe but most importantly it
needs to be adopted and translated into
concrete actions therefore close by
reiterating our call to the European
Parliament and the council that we have
no time to waste and we need to deliver
on the initiatives that will make a real
difference to the security of our
situation our report today is also a
contribution to the discussions on
internal security at the European
Council next week thank you very much
for your attention
no thank you history traces just said
oddly the last couple of years we've
seen too often terrorists determined to
attack us and attack our way of life but
we've also seen chemical attacks on our
streets and we've seen the rise of
pernicious cyber and cyber enabled
threats from States and non-state actors
in the face of all of these different
challenges as dimitra's said the
Commission's been working hard to
develop an effective security Union to
help and support the member states who
of course remain in the frontline when
it comes to keeping their citizens safe
but there is a lot that we can and that
we need to do collectively today's
report which is the sixteenth in a
series reports that we produced gives an
overview of of where we are what we've
proposed what's been agreed those the
proposals that still need to get
agreements and areas where we still have
to work to put things into practice to
get things implemented and that's what
we want to underline today there's a
window now ahead of next May's European
elections to get on and deliver to make
sure we do what we've agreed to do in
this crucial area those who are trying
to do us harm don't stand still and
neither should we over the last couple
of months as Dimitra said we've agreed
on some important measures like the ATS
system reinforcements the Schengen
information system reinforcements of key
agency ELISA but other important
proposals still remain on the table we
need to continue our work to close down
the space in which terrorists operate by
cracking down on their ability to travel
to and within the EU to access weapons
such as explosives or to obtain the
funding they need so we need to make
rapid progress on our proposals on
interoperability of our information
systems as has just been underlined this
is going to be absolutely crucial in
enabling national authorities to detect
the use of multiple and fake identities
shouldn't forget that the Berlin
Christmas market attacker was
circulating with no less than 14 fake
identities we simply can't afford to
allow terrorists and other criminals to
be recorded in different databases under
different fake identities we also call
on the coal educators to make progress
on strengthening the restrictions on
explosive precursors which as we've seen
have been used to make homemade bombs
too terrible effect and on facilitating
law enforcement access to financial
information so that we can follow the
money and on the enhancement of ID cards
and residence documents we all agree the
prevention is better than cure so we're
also working to counter radicalization
both off and on line president Jonker
announced in this state of Union speech
a key proposal as Dimitri's has just
recalled to tackle terrorists content
online this will see the creation of
removal orders issued by member state
authorities and requiring internet
platforms to take down this illegal
content within one hour while ensuring
protection of fundamental rights this is
really crucial terrorists content online
has been linked to every single one of
the terrorist attacks across Europe over
the last two years whether through
incitement instruction or glorification
and we have to make rapid progress
against this kind of content the
platforms have cooperated with us up to
a point but overall they have not acted
quickly enough or indeed done enough in
the face of this serious threat second
we need to strengthen our resilience in
the face of cyber and cyber enabled
threats for anyone who's still in any
any doubt about whether that kind of
threat is a real challenge we've seen
the Russian GRU agents caught red-handed
hacking the OPCW in the Netherlands
without a cathedral anywhere in sight
cyber is a weapon of choice not only of
organized crime but also state and
hostile act
who are looking to manipulate public
opinion to raise questions or subvert
our democratic processes and
institutions the Commission's argue for
some time that we need to be better
prepared more resilient better defended
and with real and effective deterrence
against would-be cyber attackers that's
why we put forward a package last year
based around those three pillars and we
now need the council and Parliament to
reach agreement on a key element of the
follow-up the cybersecurity act by the
end of the year to create a genuine EU
cybersecurity agency to help set
standards and coordinate the response to
large-scale cyber incidents and when it
comes to deterrence as dimitra's
mentioned the recent proposals that we
brought forward aiming to improve
cross-border gathering of electronic
evidence for criminal proceedings will
significantly enhance the ability of law
enforcement to investigate and prosecute
cyber crime those proposals also need to
be adopted as soon as possible as well
as these classic cyber threats if you
like we've also taken action against
growing and in some ways more insidious
kind of cyber threats attempted
interference or manipulation of our
elections that means not only protecting
our electoral systems and data against
malware disruption and distortion but
also tackling the tools of online cyber
enable manipulation hacks leaks fake
news and the misuse of mind personal
data president Juncker announced last
month a package on election security
including changes to party funding rules
which need to be fast-tracked to be in
place in time for next spring's
elections and we're organizing a
conference on election security bringing
together all the key actors here next
week finally we need to ensure that
measures which have been adopted and
have entered into force are properly
implemented any failure to do this just
create a weak link in the chain of
European security we've seen progress in
some important
areas with the implementation for
example of the EU PNR directive which is
a vital tool for tracking movements of
terrorists and serious criminals and
there are now only eight more member
states who have to complete the
transposition of this directive but we
need more effort in a number of other
areas the data protection law
enforcement directive that enables
police forces to work together better at
the NIST directive which is a vital
building block of our cyber security the
directive on combating terrorism which
creates a legal basis for cooperation
across our member states incorporating
terrorism the directive on control and
acquisition and possession of of weapons
firearms all of these need an extra push
an extra effort by our member states to
implement and on CBRN as the events in
Salisbury showed this is a real threat
and we need now to take practical steps
to implement our action plan it's vital
that we see the measures that we've all
agreed put into practice the Commission
will continue to work with and support
the member states to do this but don't
be under any misapprehension if
necessary we will use our enforcement
powers to get this done thank you thank
you very much thank you both
the German Group has missed my welcome
they came in the mean time so welcome
we'll come in then let's start with your
questions start with the issue at stake
yes
you
hello yes hi Nikolai Nielsen you
observer this is a question for
commissioner King it's a question
dealing with what commissioner Java last
month in an interview would develop
described as a serious security risk and
she was talking about the issue of
golden visas where residency and
citizens can be bought
in the European Union and I was wanted
to wanted to get your view on this do
you agree with that assessment
our golden visas in particular
citizenships sold to foreign oil arks in
Malta Cyprus Austria Bulgaria a serious
security risk and do you believe that
should be regulated with binding rules
at the EU level thank you thank you let
me tell you that we are following this
issue very very closely we have
committed to present to producing a
report on national schemes granting EU
citizenship to investors describing
current national law and practice
appropriate commission actions in this
area and guidance for member states
including on the necessary background
checks for applicants welcome this is
currently being finalized we envisage
publishing this report on schemes
granting EU citizenship to investors by
the end of this year
so please wait at the back
thank you very much Hughes for PressTV I
know both the commissioners avramopoulos
and commissioner King mentioned the
issue of radicalization we know it's a
big issue online you mentioned that and
also in prisons we've also seen many
reports down through the years in
relation to radicalization in mosques
and in community groups and so on we had
an issue here even locally in Belgium in
Brussels just up the road in terms of I
suppose funding from Saudi Arabia for we
hear this phrase Wahhabism you know
extreme ideology and in all of these
security Union press conferences I've
never mentioned or talked about so is
that on your radar at all in terms of
maybe I know it's a very sensitive issue
I I'm not being facetious but we sell so
many billions euro worth of arms to
Saudi Arabia from your country and
Germany France Italy Spain Sweden and so
on
in terms of maybe contacting a country
like Saudi Arabia and saying what's
going on here right that our efforts to
tackle radicalization need to be even
further reinforced wherever it comes
from I hasten to add we often rightly
focus on the challenges of extremist
jihadi based radicalization but it's not
the only challenge that we face from
radicalization that can lead to violence
on our streets as unfortunately has been
illustrated by some of the far-right
radicalization that we also have to keep
in mind so for that reason we have just
completed a year-long review of what
we're doing on tackling radicalization
in particular in our communities
in prisons with young people and we're
having a meeting later this week on
Thursday of this week which Demetrius
and I will be opening bringing together
for the first time a new reinforced
network of not only the absolutely
crucial frontline NGOs and civil society
actors
to tackle these issues but also national
and local administrations that are
challenged with these issues I
personally think that we have a lot to
do at the level of local and city
authorities to understand what's going
on in a particular set of circumstances
and to take appropriate measures so that
meetings going to discuss a range of
issues it is going to discuss the
challenges of religious-based
extremism we can have a frank exchange
of the different experiences across
different member states who obviously
have different traditions and sometimes
different legal frameworks but it's also
going to look at what more we can do to
help vulnerable often young people and
what we can do about the big challenge
of radicalization in prisons so your
questions very timely and look forward
to giving you some account of the
exchanges we have at the conference that
we're opening on Thursday ok let's move
to the right
you
I'd welcome
yet okay it's Jennifer Rankin at the
Guardian first question could you update
us on the Commission's No Deal planning
when it comes to security so you
mentioned the sis to database for
example and if the UK leaves the EU
about a deal there will be big
consequences for the whole of the EU for
security so could you could you outline
us the Commission's thinking in this
area and a second question you've both
heard from Michel Barnier this morning
his update on the brexit talks so did
you have you left that meeting feeling
that decisive progress is is likely next
week at the council already briefed
today the solids on the state of play of
the negotiations miss Michelle Bernie's
and his team are working day and night
to reach a deal but we are not there I
just add because I suspect there might
be one or two others in the audience who
want to pursue different angles of that
line of questioning Michel Barnier is
doing his job we're doing our jobs and
the awesome issues that will need to be
addressed in the context of a future
partnership including on security and
we've both said publicly on many
occasions in the past as indeed as
Michel Barnier that there's a strong
shared self-interest in find your way of
maintaining cooperation on security if
that proves to be possible I don't know
what will be the outcome of these
negotiations let's hope that we are
going to have a positive end but as far
as security is concerned it is very
important in order to instill more
security or citizens and safety for our
countries to keep working together in
the
okay then I had one left one for the
floor as well you did me ya vision
unfortunately and it's not just a matter
of fortunate or fortune we had not many
terrorist attacks lately but we had many
problems of data leaks and data breaches
so with this increase the
interconnection interoperability
are you sure that data in the hands of
state structures are better protected
and data into commercial services is
that a matter of concern for you you're
right to raise the importance of making
sure that we have our data protection
effectively implemented that's of course
why very Rover has been so consistent in
pursuing agreement on and now
implementation of the GDP our and that
affects everybody that affects
businesses it affects the big platforms
but it also affects a public
administrations and public authorities
everybody is going to be held to the
highest standards around data protection
you linked it in your question to what
we've been talking about on
interoperability I just want to be
absolutely clear about this
interoperability is about being able to
use our existing databases better or
more effectively we asked a couple of
years ago those on the front line the
policeman the border guards the customs
officers the immigration officers how we
could help them to do their job their
job to help keep us safe and they said
consistently that they needed timely
access to accurate information and that
they found that the current network of
systems that we have EU wide law
enforcement database systems visa
systems and other systems that exist
already or are going to be created in
the next couple of years
a too siloed too cumbersome and too slow
to use for them to do their jobs and
that's what interoperability
about it's about being able to use
existing data effectively and
efficiently it will not change any of
the existing rules and protections
around that data so please don't think
that because we're trying to be
efficient and support those on the front
line that we are putting at risk in any
way the data that is in those databases
and is protected to a high standard
Julian said the interoperability is not
about collecting more and more new data
it is targeted and I can tell you an
intelligent way of using the existing
information held in our systems to best
effect it will build on the existing
ecosystems that will keep the specific
purpose limitations access and data
retention our approach remains data
protection by design and by default
built into the interoperability
interoperability components data
processing will be limited to what is
strictly a necessary and proportionate
in line with existing purpose new angles
issues not covered yes TV news you've
been updated by Michel Barnier this
morning you're saying that you're not
there yet buck you ate the security
union questions and then we'll come back
to that yes Olivia hi back Thank You
Oliver came for the Austrian newspaper
depressors since the SIS database was
mentioned it's one of the call basically
one of the backbones
security in Europe I'd be interested in
both of your views on the case of the
Ukrainian human rights activist nude
Milla Kozlovsky who actually is married
to a pole who's been living in Poland
and who upon upon instigation of the
Polish government was refused to entry
into the Schengen area because she
supposedly poses a security risk as her
husband is very critical of the Polish
government is this in your view an abuse
of the SIS and do you think does it
merit an infringement procedure against
Poland thank you I think you go too far
by even thinking of infringement
procedures you know the sis roots are
very very clear they have to be
respected by everybody and this system I
can tell you works properly I don't want
to get in details on this issue you know
that the European prop policy in general
is defined by the rule of law respect of
human rights and it's bound by
international conventions okay anything
else security liberated yes David David
Price your democracy last week American
vice president pence denounced the
Chinese efforts to use Google to control
the population relative to Google's
project dragonfly which will censor and
help control the population obviously
this is a big problem for if Google uses
it on the Western populations as well
have the Commission made any
representations to Google about this or
the Chinese government secondarily the
question of the Chinese micro spied ship
in the and the boards which apparently
of according to Bloomberg
have are now being used in lot of
industries in America and even in the
defense sector is it's affecting
European industries and European
security thank you well beyond the
bobbum the Europe industries I can tell
you that there is a basic principle upon
which our policy is built as far as the
free expression of people across the
world and we have been of them
one of the main defenders of Internet
Julian before presented the position of
the European Commission as far as the
internet providers role is concerned we
have a very strong and deep cooperation
between between us and them a
cooperation that is based on mutual
trust so as far as internet free
expression of press and free expression
of citizens full respect of their
democratic rights is a basic rule as you
said upon which the European policy is
based expression on the question of
resilience of systems which lies behind
the second part of your question we've
we've made no secret at all of our
concern to work with the Member States
to try and do whatever we can to
reinforce and assure the resilience of
our cyber infrastructure that goes all
the way back to the original set of
proposals around the NIST directive it
goes like a red thread through the
proposals we brought forward last year
for the cybersecurity Act and it's being
taken forward now in the in the
follow-up work that we're doing we do
need to be conscious that there are some
actors non-state actors and some actors
state actors who do see cyber
interference in physical systems as as
legitimate activity you mentioned China
very often the question refers to Russia
these aren't the only actors in Russia
does have the distinguishing
characteristic of being the only one as
far as I'm aware that advertising
the fact that it engages in this kind of
activity apparently is proud of it proud
enough to put it in its military
doctrine but there are other actors as
well and that's why we need to be very
serious about building our cyber
resilience that is a work underway
indeed I think there's been some press
reporting about it in the last few days
which looks not only at China but at the
need to make sure that across first of
all what we do as institutions then what
we fund and thirdly what the member
states do to look at what assurances we
have around the questions of cyber
resilience and that work will continue
in the weeks and months ahead you know
that we are in view of a new justice and
home of council that will take place in
two days in Lok Sabha where all these
issues will be discussed among the
ministers of interior of member states
of the European Union just came back
together with Julian in lyon where the
g6 meeting and to also discussed all
these issues there with our American
partners and this time we had also
Morocco who is invited or especially on
the issue of migration I'm also heading
towards Turkey
we'll be there next Monday to have
discussions again with the Turkish
government at the leadership of the
country on all these issues that are
linking Turkey with the European Union
so as you are going to have a very
interesting week ahead and I will do so
thank you you keep providing news at the
end so they will never go you want to
try your chances on yes try we won't be
here for much longer of course
Angus Walker ITV News I'm you've had a
briefing from Michele Barney a this
morning you said that we're not there
yet how would you describe how would you
describe the outstanding issues and
would you confirm there's been some sort
break through on the Northern Ireland
backstop issue I think it's a question
that you should address our good friend
Michelle Bernie okay no I'm thinking we
have exhausted this chapter is it
security related the read another
subject try your chances - yes thank you
it's on European fiscal board I'm
wondering if you had debate during the
college since the report apparently it's
quite critical of the way the European
Commission implemented disability in
growth pact or if there will be a an
answer by President Juncker or the two
Commissioner in charge of the issue
thank you there was a presentation of
the report by professor Higginson there
was a discussion around the findings
which was not at all confrontational I
would say it was rather positive and the
report you will judge for yourselves
when it will be announced later this
afternoon the public finances of the
European Union have considerably
improved in recent years the average
public deficit of Member States has
decreased from six point six in 2009 to
0.8 in 2013 and public debt is on a
downward path but more when the report
is out if it's again on breaks it I
think okay go ahead I think we have
exhausted the subject it was it was a
follow-up because I felt that my
question about a No Deal breaks it and
what it meant for security was not
really answered and what preparations
the Commission is making I understand
you want there to be cooperation in the
future partnership but if we're talking
about No Deal you are making plans can
you tell us what those plans are when it
comes concerned security but our plans
are defined bar by our goodwill
to continue our cooperation in the
future in the field of information
exchange intelligence exchange and of
course depending even more trust and
sharing the same worries and concerns on
issues of security and not I'm a goose
the heart of your question and the ITV
question as well I'm expecting to be the
last British Commissioner but I'm not
expecting to be the last Commissioner
for the security Union the last
Commissioner working on these issues so
the Commission is going to remain very
focused on taking forward work on these
issues because of the importance of
working together collectively to deal
with these cross-border
types of threats that's true today it'll
be true next year and in the future as
well as we build this security union we
build it in a way with a commitment to
effective cooperation with our partners
and allies again that's true today we
have extensive conversations with the US
for example I was there last week we saw
them we saw them together with the other
members of the g6 yesterday that'll be
true in the future too this concludes
our press conference thank you all see
you tomorrow
thank you
you
[Music]
[Music]
you